it had been the same nightmare for weeks
now but always Fading Into Echoes as he
awoke not tonight though denied he was
able to see more to hold on to the
details of his Dark Twisted dream and
the warning it contained Dr Steven
strange had once been an accomplished
surgeon yet fate had destined him to
become the sorcerer's Supreme of Earth
after a car accident claimed the use of
his hands now strange was a protector of
his world and countless others in the
vast expanse of the Multiverse a master
of the Mystic Arts wielding his skills
in sorcery and Arcane artifacts to
defend against malevolent otherworldly
threats but even he had never seen
anything like this nightmare before on
the night where the details of the dream
felt easier to keep a hold on a sleeping
Steven was shown all manner of Horrors
the world he had devoted himself to
protecting was crumbling burning all
around was death and suffering the air
shrill with the screams of tortured
innocence
to make matters worse within the dream
strange could feel the same suffering
reaching out crossing the boundaries
between realities it wasn't just his
world he saw dying it was all of them
every corner of the Multiverse falling
it turned his stomach it all felt so
real not just an anxious unconscious
fantasy of something he feared might
happen this was a warning of something
that would come to pass the dread felt
by The Sorcerer's Supreme only got worse
as he witnessed a familiar figure
injured and broken crawling free of the
rubble of a destroyed City the
flickering light of endless fires doing
little to mask the man's wounds
instantly Doctor Strange recognized the
wounded figure from the distinctive
flared cloak he War to his goatee and
dark hair graying at the temples it was
him or rather another version of him
from a different reality within the
Multiverse
help the other strange said weekly
instantly Stephen to help his
interdimensional doppelganger up what
happened here he asked concerned that
the vision of Destruction all around I
couldn't stop it the messenger strange
replied and labored breaths he was
wounded fatally barely holding on slow
down breathe Doctor Strange calmly
instructed his other self still
retaining a bedside manner from his days
as a surgeon this Vision I take it
you're trying to warn me of something
yes the dying sorcerer replied I cast a
spell that should reach you in your
sleep although sending a message across
the multiverses
he paused to wince in pain feeling his
already fading strength dwindling
further it takes a lot more than I have
left it's all right strange assured him
I can hear you I'm listening I only wish
I could do more for you it's all right
his very enforced a weak Smile by the
time this message reaches you I'll
already have been dead but you need to
be warned what happened here strange
urged it's not what has happened it's
what's coming it had to be us of course
it did the other's breaths started
slowing I tried everything I really did
but he I've never felt power like it
just tell me who Stephen shouted where
his other self was fading fast desperate
to hear the full warning before the
dream ended already Dr Strange's mind
was racing with potential candidates who
could have been responsible he knew of a
plethora of deities and destructive
creatures capable of launching attacks
on his home universe and many of whom
had time and time again there were the
likes of nightmare and Shuma glass and
of course his arch nemesis dormammu an
entity who had long desired total
control over this plane of existence
Stephen's Earth inhabited but not one of
them had the power to subjugate the
entire Multiverse in one Fell Swoop
please messenger strange rasped leading
up to Steven's ear don't make the same
mistake I did beware the Scarlet gang he
collapsed his breathing stopped as
Doctor Strange looked at the horrific
side of a man almost identical to him
dying having failed to prevent the chaos
that was now consuming everything the
sorcerer Supreme had an encyclopedic
knowledge of the Mystic Arts and all
kinds of occult beings that he had never
heard of the Scarlet King as he woke in
a cold sweat still feeling the same
dread he felt in the dream Doctor
Strange could remember the warning from
his other multiversal self it had to be
him he had to stop the Scarlet King The
Scarlet who repeated Wong Steven's
trusted friend and confident an expert
in both and martial arts as well as an
accomplished scholar Scarlet King the
other me was adamant that this thing had
to be stopped by another version of me
Doctor Strange explained having woken up
flustered with growing concern over his
vision Stephen had spent the whole
morning in the library the sanctum
santorium had long been Strange's home
and base of operations since he had
inherited the title of sorcerer's
Supreme from the ancient one
additionally the magical building in the
heart of New York's Greenwich Village
also possessed a sprawling Library
filled with tomes that contained what
was thought to be the sum total of all
occult knowledge his books were filled
with useful information on spells other
planes of existence even detailing
accounts of threats Steven had already
faced like dormammu and yet there was no
mention of any Scarlet King I don't
understand it my other selfie mentioned
it specifically by name but I can't find
a single reference to it in any texts
strange side and frustration the book of
kaglistro nothing no mention of a
Scarlet King strange Wong mused what no
I mean it's unusual you found nothing
his friend answered trying to hide a
smile at catching Steven in a joke
perhaps the book of Ashanti holds more
answers it contains all the knowledge
the great sorcerer agamoto collected on
the Mystic nope I already tried that
doctor strange interrupted I consulted
our copy on the dark hole too while I
was at it you did what Wong exclaimed
ever concerned by Steven's arrogant and
Reckless Behavior the darkhold was a
dangerous home a book of spells used
only for Pure Evil written by an elder
god named kython even though the
original true darkhold Was Out Of Reach
the knowledge contained within the copy
Stephen possessed was still perilous to
be exposed to ah relax strange replied
in a rather blase manner still
absent-mindedly flicking through the
pages of another book the Codex Imperium
damn it I need to know what it is I'm up
against he yelled in frustration Wong
you didn't see what I saw in that dream
it was chaos destruction unlike anything
I've ever felt before I understand
Stephen his fellow sorcerer answered and
as sorcerer's Supreme you hold a duty to
protect this reality from those that
would seek to threaten its safety but
this is dangerous a being we know
nothing about is rare perhaps consider
if there's a reason why we know nothing
of this Scarlet King there is some
knowledge that is not meant to be
uncovered knowledge is power old friend
Doctor Strange retorted if I'm gonna do
my duty to protect our reality I need to
know anything that will give me an edge
I'll be in my study with that the
sorcerer Supreme Strode off to a private
corner of the sanctum he spent the next
few Restless hours using his Mastery of
the occult to peer into the future
understanding the mystical mechanics of
time in the way he did when Steven was
aware that there was no singular future
but rather Millions upon millions of
possible outcomes a web of potential
courses that fate could take and any
decision made could create a new strand
in this already Tangled mess still there
was no outcome where any Scarlet King
existed however it was then that doctor
strange realized what he had been
missing a detail so small that it had
gone unnoticed but so crucial that it
changed his entire approach he had been
thinking of the situation entirely wrong
in an insular fashion that focused
solely on his own reality his universe
but the warning had come from across the
Multiverse from another strange in
another world what's more was the
feeling the sense he'd felt during the
nightmare although he knew nothing of
his enemy strange could tell the
destruction the Scarlet King was capable
of had the reach to threaten all corners
of the Multiverse this wasn't just a
threat to his world but all worlds
Strange's search for answers about the
Scarlet King had proved fruitless thus
far yet remembering this was a threat
coming from across the vastness of the
infinite Multiverse oddly seemed to to
provide some sense of comfort because
there was one entity he did know of who
might be able to help hands a glow with
magic Doctor Strange performed the
correct ritual he knew would allow him
to communicate with the Living Tribunal
sure enough the room around him faded
away and he was presented with the
highest Authority in the Multiverse The
Towering vastly powerful entity was
humanoid in shape save for a head
floating separate from its shoulders
with three faces one fully hooded one
half and the other uncovered the
sorcerer's Supreme had conversed on a
few occasions with the entity enough to
know it was responsible for safeguarding
the Multiverse to prevent universes from
amassing too much power in case they
threatened others maintain balance which
made the fact it had done nothing to
prevent the imminent danger of the
Scarlet King all the more concerning
speak strange Living Tribunal I've come
seeking answers Doctor Strange replied
there is a being an entity that poses a
threat to my world world and all others
in the Multiverse I am not aware of such
a threat
the multiversal Arbiter replied please
strange urged it's out there and I need
to be the one to stop it there's no
information on it in my universe so I
ask you please tell me where I can find
someone anyone who knows about the
Scarlet King there was a silence for a
moment as the different faces of the
Living Tribunal conferred all three had
to agree on whether or not it could
interfere the answers you seek lie
beyond your universe
the tribunal finally answered we are in
agreement
I will send you there
but exercise caution Stephen strain
in a Flash Doctor Strange had appeared
somewhere new the room was dark filthy
nothing short of Bleak but still was a
far cry from the destruction he had seen
in this Vision the walls were covered in
scribbled writing that had seemingly
been scrawled over every Surface by
someone in a state of Madness there was
one that caught Dr Strange attention a
figure adorned in red armor large
antler-like horns protruding from his
head it didn't take someone with as much
knowledge of sorcerer's Supreme to know
this was a drawing of The elusive
Scarlet King himself who's there a voice
rasped Stephen turned to see an old man
withered and alone laying on a grimy
hospital bed in the corner of the room
sorry I I didn't see you he said calmly
cautiously approaching only lowering his
guard when he heard the elderly man give
a horse cough you're very sick strange
remarked dying I think the man replied
are you Foundation Foundation the
sorcerer echoed in confusion yes yes
don't be surprised I know all about them
the anonymous man said weekly I haven't
forgotten when I used to work there or
how they felt about what I know though
they'd stop at nothing to silence me God
knows they've tried over the years
listen I was sent here because I need
answers Doctor Strange interrupted aware
of the impending threat he felt he
needed to avert so uh Mr doctor
the old man corrected Dr Robert Montauk
Dr Montauk Steven echoed what can you
tell me about the Scarlet King Montauk
started chuckling a dry wheezing sound
almost like he was taunting the sorcerer
his laughter lasted far longer than that
of a sane man paired with the drawings
and markings on the walls Stephen was
certain something inside Robert Montauk
was broken oh I could tell you so much
about the Scarlet gang I was one of his
children once so long ago now he said a
loud hacking cough brought on by his
laughter forcing its way out of
montauk's throat
but that's his strength you see being
known being understood look this being
is threatening my world I need to know
how I'm supposed to stop him strange ass
stop him
Dr Montauk chuckled at him what makes
you think you can I was told I have to
the sorcerer's Supreme admitted it has
to be me and if you won't tell me what I
need to know that I'm very sorry
normally I'd never do this but in the
grand calculus of the Multiverse there's
nothing I won't sacrifice to protect it
with the wave of his hands Dr Strange
conjured his third eye which snapped
open in the center of his forehead it
functioned as an organic manifestation
of his Amulet the powerful mystical
artifact known as the eye of agamoto and
through it Stephen peered into Dr
montauk's fractured mind seeking out the
information he was withholding about the
Scarlet King no no no you can't Montauk
shouted his frail withered hands
gripping his temples as he felt the
sorcerer invading his memories I'm sorry
strange repeated but knowledge is power
and I need to know how to stop the
Scarlet King you think knowledge is
power the old man rasped it's more than
that to him it's a weapon his weapon the
more we know about him it was too late
Doctor Strange had found what he was
looking for years earlier Dr Robert
Montauk had been working at the SCP
Foundation and that uncovered the true
nature of scp-001 tough toe's proposal
otherwise known as The Scarlet King The
King was an elder god a force of pure
chaos and the manifestation of a hatred
for modernity but it was far worse than
that a huge Crimson crack split through
the concrete wall a doorway to the
Scarlet King's domain pulling himself
out of Robert montauk's mind the second
he realized his mistake Doctor Strange
was still reeling as the portal opened
how could he have been so stupid his
nightmare hadn't been a warning to
prevent what was coming it was either a
warning to stay away or a trap snapping
back to awareness Steven found he was no
longer in the filthy room where the
dying Dr Robert Montauk lay instead he
was in a vast multiversal void a space
between universes and there among the
huge expanse of nothingness stood the
Scarlet King he Tower over Doctor
Strange his physical form adorned in
armored the shade of blood atop his head
was a crown-like ornament the large
antlers jutting out above his hands were
gnarled claws clenched into massive
fists and his many eyes were looking at
Stephen having seen inside montauk's
mind Doctor Strange had realized all too
late that the Scarlet King was more than
just an ancient evil being and a desire
to return to a more violent age but if
nobody talked about him he would gain no
further power the Scarlet King had only
grown in strength the more the SCP
Foundation had tried to learn about him
and now the sorcerer Supreme himself had
done the same the king had achieved even
greater power thanks to strange falling
into his trap enough to open a Gateway
and bring him here you already know
the Scarlet King snarled his voice
sounding like billions upon billions of
insects chittering through Montauk you
know
Stephen looked in horror at the
interdimensional Abomination even just
by observing him being able to receive
his physical form he was unintentionally
empowering The Entity but living idea or
not strange had seen the destruction
that the Scarlet King could unfurl on
the Multiverse by the hoary hosts of
hoggoth Doctor Strange declared
summoning up a spell that he hoped would
reverse whatever power the king
possessed you will not harm my world nor
any others unleashing his magic in a
blast of light the beam struck the
Scarlet King the elder god was harmed
but not undone the force of the Mystic
Arts being almost as ancient as the
Scarlet King was and thus he could still
be hurt the Scarlet King raised a mighty
fist bringing it slamming down towards
Stephen it was barely able to cast The
Shield of seraphim creating a protective
circle of mystical energy that formed a
barrier between strange and the oncoming
attack as the descending gigantic Fist
of the Scarlet King was deflected he
instantly brought his other down in a
vicious attack the sheer force of it
broke Steven's concentration causing the
shield to dissipate barely withstanding
enough of the King's Physical strength
to prevent the sorcerer from being
knocked down it was like one magically
powered ant fighting against a being
impossibly bigger that could stomp
strange out of existence in seconds but
even failing to the imperceptible ground
of the Void Doctor Strange didn't let up
refusing to relent and let the Scarlet
King unleash his wrath on the Multiverse
his cloak of levitation lifted him back
to his feet and with a wave of both
hands Stephen burst into multiple astral
projected copies of himself the images
of Icon the multiple doctors strangers
floated independently through the air
surrounding the Scarlet King then as
every Stephen gave an outward flick of
his wrist the Crimson bands of xidarock
flew from their hands the bright red
belts of energy virtually indestructible
bound the powerful chaotic King lashing
around his physical form Doctor Strange
being able to see and perceive the
Scarlet King was granting his adversary
power he pulled with all his physical
strength the Crimson bands starting to
wane slackening despite Strange's
efforts to keep all his duplicates
holding on ripping the bands in his huge
gnarled hands the Scarlet King swung the
multiple strangers around forcing them
all back into the same singular body as
they collided still holding the one
remaining Crimson band of sirach the
Scarlet King started to drag Stephen
towards him the king didn't want him
dead strange knew it he'd be tortured
made and unmade even until the entity
forced him to use his third eye again
like he had done to Dr Montauk if Doctor
Strange could fully comprehend the
Scarlet King's nature origin and
ideology then the king would be able to
achieve his full strength that was the
Trap the sorcerer Supreme had been lured
into his own arrogance his need to be
the one who saved the Multiverse the man
holding the scalpel was a weakness the
Scarlet King was prepared to exploit in
order to achieve the power he needed to
overthrow the Multiverse there was only
one thing left that doctor strange could
do one last Stitch effort it was a long
shot but he hoped it would be enough
releasing his remaining band Steven
began casting a spell to send a message
to another of his selves somewhere else
in the Multiverse he could hear the
Scarlet King blooming behind him ready
to strike maybe the king would kill him
but strange wouldn't let that stopping
him cast his spell his warning would
reach the other self even after death in
the form of a dream a warning not to
make the same mistake as this strange
had to not go searching for the Scarlet
King now go check out Deadpool vs
scp-682 and scp-001 the Scarlet King for
more wild battles and Eldritch monsters